I lived in New York for years,
and I think it has some of
the best food in the world.
I've invited my friend
Harry Kersh over from the UK
to teach him how we do things
slightly differently over here.
We'll be visiting four of
the top-rated bagel spots
across the city all in one day
to see if we can find
New York's best bagel.
This is "Food Tours."
Our first stop of the day is
at Utopia Bagels in Queens.
We're at Utopia Bagels in
Queens on Utopia Parkway.
Second-best Fountains of Wayne album.
And the reason I took you
here is because this place,
it's got dynamite bagels,
and although we're off the beaten path,
so maybe not a lot of
tourists come out here,
don't get me wrong, buddy.
They make so many bagels here.
Over 100,000 a week.
That's a lot of bagels.
Dude, they go through
2 tons of flour a day.
So many bagels!
Joe: Dude, the oven they
got in there is from 1947,
which of course was ...
during World War II?
Just after.
Joe: Yes.
So I figured for the
day, every place we go,
we're getting the
traditional New York City
bagels and lox.
Harry: Perfect.
Joe: Have you ever had
bagels and lox before?
I have.
In the UK we call it a salmon
and cream cheese bagel.
Oh, my God.
You have a lot to learn, my friend.
What do you think makes a good bagel?
Harry: So, I'm looking for
a nice golden brown bagel.
I want it seasoned on both sides.
So if we got, like, everything bagel,
we need toppings on
the top and the bottom.
Don't be skimping on it.
Crackly crust on the outside,
nice and chewy inside.
And then the toppings have
got to be good as well.
We need the salmon to be good,
the cream cheese to be good.
Everything's got to work together.
Joe: Yes. I agree.
For me, what I look for
is what tastes the best.
That helps on a food show.
Some places attempt to just overfill
for the sake of overfilling it,
whereas actually, like, I don't want that.
I'd rather have fewer toppings,
and therefore it holds together
much better when you eat it.
I want everything in one bite.
So don't be stacking.
Interesting thing about bagels and lox,
which I've heard before and
I cannot confirm or deny
but it sounds like it's true,
and that's all we need for the internet,
is that bagels and lox
became popular because
it was a reaction to eggs
Benedict, which wasn't kosher.
And you're half Jewish?
I am half Jewish, yeah.
Joe: Have you ever gone
kosher or done anything?
No, I'm not a very good Jew.
I'm 50% Ashkenazi Jewish,
which is the type of Jewish
where we kind of moved to
Eastern Europe and then many
people then came to the US.
So, honestly, they've kind of
brought the bagels with them.
So I feel like I'm experiencing, like,
a spiritual homecoming with this episode.
I'm very excited.
Joe: I'm starving.
Harry: I'm so hungry.
Joe: All right.
Hold the table. I'm
going to get some bagels.
Harry: I got it.
Joe: Pew!
Harry: Ooh!
Joe: Look at this beast.
Harry: Ooh, mama!
There you go.
Harry: Man. Look at this thing!
Look how much lox they gave us, bro.
Harry: That is thick.
Joe: This look good, right?
Incredible amount of lox, as you can see.
Tomato, capers, cream cheese.
Also got raw red onion on there.
All on an everything bagel.
First impressions, what do you think?
Harry: This looks fantastic.
Very pretty to look at.
Like you say, generous with the salmon.
I will say the tomato kind
of blends in with the salmon.
So for a second I thought
it was just, like,
a pure wedge of salmon.
Joe: Let's separate it.
Harry: Some of it is tomato.
Joe: That's pretty good.
Harry: Still pretty generous.
I'm not complaining.
Bagel's still a little bit
warm, which excites me a lot.
You feeling that?
Joe: Fresh. I mean, these are
straight out of the oven, the 1947 oven.
Harry: Should we give it a try?
Yeah. Oh, yeah.
Mm. Mm!
Oh, man.
Joe: The crunch.
Harry: Mm-hmm.
That taste like a bagel you're
getting over there in London?
This is the first bagel
I've had in New York,
and it already might be
better than any bagel
I've had in London.
Believe it. You guys normally
get it with the capers
and raw red onion and that stuff?
Not really. Some delis
might do it to order.
I'd say the standard one in the UK
if you ask for, like, a bagel and lox
or a bagel with salmon and cream cheese
will just be salmon and cream cheese,
without the onion, without the
tomato, without the capers.
It's very much just a plain sandwich.
But I'm liking all these toppings.
I do think they work together.
Joe: Yeah, it's great.
I would've never thought
before having this —
the, like, fish for breakfast
would kind of turn me off.
But that's amazing.
Right? It's so delicious.
Harry: I'd say fish for
breakfast isn't something
that's super uncommon to Europeans.
I think in Jewish culture,
in Eastern European culture,
and even in Scottish culture,
like, kippers for breakfast,
you will find fish on the
menu at a breakfast place.
So that's not super weird to us.
But yeah, this really, really works.
Joe: Yeah.
Harry: I was worried when I
saw that tomato is in this.
Generally speaking,
not a huge fan of tomatoes in sandwiches,
but this really works.
It's actually got some crunch to it.
A little bit of flavor.
I think they've actually
seasoned it, which is crucial.
Joe: Yeah. As you can tell, it's clutch
for places like this, the fact
that they make the bagels,
they're just making them all day,
so they're getting them
right out of the oven.
At other places, they got them
morning or the night before.
These bagels, this is amazing
how great these bagels are.
You can really, really
taste the freshness.
You bite into it and there's
steam coming out of it.
Joe: They're making 15,000 of these a day.
Harry: That's so many.
Joe: Right? That's a lot.
That's really good to
know that you can come in
pretty much any time of day
and get a fresh bagel, though.
It does make a difference.
Joe: That's how they do it here. Yeah.
And anyone will tell
you, the breakfast meal,
you gotta pair with a beverage.
I of course went with coffee,
and you of course got, yeah.
How does that pair with the blue Gatorade?
Perfectly. So well.
When in Rome, you know?
Is this a European thing right here?
Gatorade for breakfast?
This is not, no.
This is just me being a little bit sleepy.
We're like pro athletes, man.
We've got to eat our way
through New York today.
We need as many
electrolytes as we can get.
Yeah. Yeah. I agree.
I will say, I think this
is a very, very good bagel.
It had all the elements that I wanted.
The bagel itself was fantastic.
Crunchy on the outside,
chewy on the inside.
Everything held together
pretty well, despite the fact
that they were generous
but not too generous.
They didn't stack.
Harry: They didn't stack. No stacking.
So yeah, I think this might
be one to beat, you know?
It's a good start.
Well, I'm ready to hit it. You
want to go to the next place?
Harry: I think so.
Joe: Let's go.
Our next location has been
in the New York bagel game
for over 32 years.
Liberty Bagels.
All right. Look at me.
Liberty Bagel, Queens.
Not to be confused with the
location that's in Manhattan.
This is the other one.
Or the Statue of Liberty.
Different place.
And we're currently not
inside the Statue of Liberty.
I want make it clear, that. I know you had
asked if I had gone there.
Harry: Just to clarify. Yep.
Joe: We're nowhere near it, I don't think.
This spot, fantastic
bagels. I love this place.
Also, I noticed on the menu
they have a rainbow bagel.
You probably saw that all
over the grams of Insta.
Yeah, I mean, I'm seeing posters.
It says the "home of the rainbow bagel."
Were these guys, like,
one of the first to do it?
No clue.
[Harry laughs]
Kind of like how you see
the signs that's like,
"Best in New York City,"
and the bagel shops,
a lot of them are like,
"Home of the rainbow bagel."
We're definitely getting
another bagel with the lox,
the cream cheese, the
capers, the whole thing.
I also do want to get a
rainbow bagel for you to try.
I mean, it's like, it became
a New York City institution,
for better or for worse.
So we'll get one of those as well.
Yeah, the rainbow bagel's
kind of like a 2017 gimmick.
But, you know,
feel like Insider specifically
owes a lot to that.
Yes, they do, and I was part of that,
and you're welcome, and
I'm sorry? Whatever.
We can tell the viewers
at home we actually have
a conference room in our
office called Rainbow Bagel.
That is how deeply the Insider connection
with rainbow bagels run.
So yeah, I guess we can
try one of those as well.
But the lox is the main event.
That'll be fun too.
Joe: So, I'm going on what's
on the picture, right?
So this one I want to
point out has scallions
and scallion cream cheese,
a favorite of mine,
but it does not have
red onion. OK with that?
Also comes on the poppy seed bun,
so all urine tests are off.
Good. I will not let anyone
test my pee in the next few days
just to be on the safe side. Uh-huh.
I'm excited.
Joe: I picked this location because
at their other location,
in Manhattan, is considered
the best bagel in New
York City by Tripadvisor.
And I couldn't imagine it
tasting that much different
there than here.
But the good people at Tripadvisor
said that Liberty Bagels are No. 1.
We're going to see if Joe
Public knows their stuff
when it comes to bagels, then.
If there's one thing I've learned
in my years on this planet
is that what everyone says on the internet
is probably correct all the time.
I think that is absolutely true.
I like it in here. Nice
vibe, friendly staff.
I'm excited to try the bagels.
Joe: Feast your eyes on this, my guy.
Oh, ho-ho-ho-ho-hm-mm!
They definitely made it
more obvious that the tomato
and the salmon are two different zones.
Yeah. Distinct layers there.
Joe: Again, a lot of people,
they think it's quality
if it's piled high in the fish.
You want everything in one bite.
I don't want just one bite of fish.
I don't want to OD on the fish.
I want a taste of everything.
Quality over quantity, I think.
Yeah, it's important.
Joe: Yeah. I think proportion-wise —
and very generous with the cream cheese,
also what I like. Capers and scallions.
Harry: And this thing is
covered in poppy seeds.
Top and bottom, good coverage.
Joe: See that there? Ready to jump in?
Harry: I'm so ready.
Joe: Let's do it.
Harry: Let's go, man.
Uh-oh!
Had a bit of a — oh.
Mine did smoosh a little bit.
Harry: Little bit of smooshing.
I'm also getting poppy seeds everywhere.
Tomato's good. Quite firm.
Good bite to the tomato.
The bagel's fantastic.
Harry: The bagel is really good.
It's a fresh bagel.
Yep. I'd say maybe not the
crunchiest on the outside,
but the inner texture
is really, really good.
That's got that chew
that you know and love.
Joe: Now that we've had a
bite, I want to say that
I'm a bit biased towards
scallion cream cheese
and the scallion versus the red onion.
I'm not saying that it's
my favorite everywhere,
but knowing that made this more
of an enjoyable bite for me.
I do love red onion, don't get me wrong.
Scallions, I like.
Yeah, I don't think I miss the red onion
at all, to be honest.
Joe: Because you're getting
that onioniness, that savoriness
from two locations. Two ingredients.
Little one-two allium punch there.
There's no lack of want when
it comes to oniony flavor,
is that what I'm trying to say?
What I'm tasting the
least though is the fish.
I'm not getting a lot
of the salmon in here.
Let me get another bite.
Harry: I kind of disagree.
I feel like it's got a
reasonably strong flavor.
I don't know. So, like, in the UK,
if you ever get a salmon
and cream cheese bagel,
you're going to get smoked salmon.
Is that an everywhere thing in the US
or is that kind of optional?
It's not. It's to the place's discretion.
I'm glad you asked that.
So it's not always going to be smoked.
I don't think it's smoked here, is it?
Harry: Maybe quite mildly.
Definitely not a strong smoky flavor,
but I do think it's got
a good flavor to it.
Maybe it's getting slightly lost
in the scallion cream cheese, for example.
Joe: Yeah, that could be it.
And like I say, they were
quite generous on the capers,
which does mean that when
you bite into one of those
for a second, it's like, boom.
That's all you can taste.
I feel the capers stand
out more in this one.
I'm not quite sure why
or how I feel about that.
I think in general the
ratio is pretty good though.
I'm not that mad about the ratio.
Look at the cream cheese, man. Generous.
Joe: They were generous
with the cream cheese,
which is always nice.
But that's making it squishy, man.
You're squishing.
I quite like when you get a cream cheese
and it's quite sour and a bit tangy.
I'd say this one's more
on the mild, creamy side.
That's really funny because
I'm the exact opposite.
I want the cream cheese
to be, like, just fine,
because to me I want the bagel
to be the star of the show.
So is this more up your
street and you're quite happy
with the way that this cream cheese works?
I am, as far as the way
that the cream cheese
does or does not stand out.
I think, see, I'm just,
I'm, like, a savory onion,
I'm an oniony boy. All right?
My persona is just onion.
So you're an oniony boy.
I'm more of a tang boy, I would say.
I'm more of a tangy boy.
I want a bit of tang
from the cream cheese.
The capers, I like.
Extra tang, you know.
You ate — come on, man.
Harry: I couldn't stop myself,
man. I couldn't stop myself.
It was a good bagel.
RIP the last place we have to go to,
because you're just going to be like,
"How is it?" "Fine. Let's go home."
All right. You couldn't come to New York
without trying a rainbow bagel.
Hang on.
I didn't say the rainbow bagel's good.
It just became uniquely New York
for maybe the wrong reasons.
It was a viral sensation.
So, wa-pow.
Harry: Oh, here we go.
Joe: Well, and also, I
got sweet birthday cake.
Harry: Oh that's, like, vibrant.
Joe: I know, right? Ugh.
Harry: Oh, man.
Look at this thing!
Charlie: All of those colors
are banned in the UK.
Joe: Yeah. You're going to
eat this and then be, like,
really aggressive for some unknown reason.
More hyperactive than I've ever been.
Joe: You can't get this
red in your country.
So you say you've had this before?
Joe: Yeah, I have.
Harry: And this is the
birthday cake cream cheese?
Joe: Yeah, little more food
coloring for you, my guy.
Harry: I can't say I'm
thrilled about this,
but let's give it a try.
Joe: Ew.
Like frosting.
Harry: Mm-hmm.
Joe: Who doesn't like
a bagel with frosting?
Harry: I don't actually hate it
as much as I thought I would.
It's like a dessert bagel, right?
Joe: We're adding frosting.
It's like a slice of cake.
I certainly couldn't
handle one in the morning.
I certainly would not be, like,
having that on the way to work.
I would walk into the office,
like, flipping tables.
"Let's go!"
Like, that sugar high would
just go right to my brain.
And then 20 minutes
later, asleep at my desk.
Americans love dessert for breakfast.
We do, don't we?
You guys love pancakes, waffles,
doughnuts for breakfast.
Joe: Our cereal is really sweet, right?
So I don't know if you
can really draw the line
at a rainbow bagel with cream cheese.
But I will say, texture on
this bagel, really good.
I would say this one
has maybe even more —
Uh-oh.
This one might have even more
of a kind of crispy outside.
Joe: Than what?
Than the previous one we just tried.
Joe: So if you were to order again,
you'd get this with the rainbow bagel?
Harry: No, I think maybe
I just hope that they
had a fresh poppy seed.
Let me cleanse my palate
with a real bagel.
Harry: Get some savory back
in you. Couple of capers.
Back online. No time to waste, my man.
Ready for the next bagel?
I am, yeah. Can we run there
so that I can burn off this energy high?
Joe: That was the plan.
Harry: Cool. Sweet. Let's go.
No, immediately not working.
Joe: From Queens, we made
our way into Manhattan
to continue our bagel tour.
Next up, Tompkins Square Bagels.
All right, we're at Tompkins Square Bagels
right by the Tompkins
Square, in the East Village.
This place is amazing.
Also another spot that does
the kettle boil for the bagels.
I haven't explained that
to you yet. I will now.
Take the dough, throw
it in some boiling water
right before they bake it.
It gives the outside
of it that really nice,
crisp, almost crackery crust.
Nice. All I know about this place is that
it's Timothée Chalamet's
favorite bagel in New York.
And who is that?
He's a guy.
Joe: OK.
Harry: Hit me with some bagel facts, Joe.
Joe: All right, bagel
facts. You ready? All right.
Created by Eastern European
Jewish communities.
Originated in Poland.
Harry: Mm-hmm.
It was food often given
to women in childbirth.
The circle shape represents
life cycle and good luck.
There you go.
Truly is everything in a bagel, you know?
Yeah.
They made a reference to
the whole circle of life
or death in "Everything
Everywhere All at Once."
Yes. And "The Lion King."
There's bagels in "The Lion King"?
Harry: No, but there's a circle of life.
Joe: Oh.
Harry: Yeah. Close enough.
Joe: But there's a everything bagel in
"Everything Everywhere All at Once."
Harry: There is, correct.
Joe: Everything —
I just made the connection
it's the everything.
Harry: Mm-hmm.
I can't help it, I can't
watch anything without, like,
having two other screens in front of me.
You need, like, "Family Guy" clips playing
while you watch a movie.
And at the end, I'm like,
"Yeah, yeah, I got it.
Totally got it."
Harry: "I got the gist. It's fine."
Man, it's been, what, like, an hour
since we last ate a bagel?
Joe: I don't know about
you, but I'm starving.
Harry: I could go for a bagel right now.
Joe: Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho.
Bro, what the hell! Are you kidding me?
Harry: That thing is stacked!
Thank you! Here we go.
Joe: All right. So, I don't
know if you've noticed,
but this one has got a lot of stuff.
So this is a packed-out bagel.
Joe: Cream cheese, sesame bagel.
Harry: Mm-hmm. Capers.
Capers involved again.
Joe: Got them capey boys.
Harry: It's got all the key elements.
It's got the sesame seeds
on the top and the bottom.
Joe: Yep. You've mentioned that before,
where you're like, "Oh,
this stuff's on the top
and the bottom." Like, it always is.
Is it not like that in the UK?
Not really, no.
Joe: No! So you get a
bagel, it's just on the top?
I mean, sesame bagels
aren't even that common.
Some of them will be.
I feel like if you do get
one, often just on one side.
That's not normal.
Very hard to come by an everything
bagel in the UK as well.
So in terms of the actual bagel options,
we're pretty limited, whereas over here
you guys have got it figured out.
This is beautiful. I just
kind of want to stare at this
for a bit longer before I bite into it.
I will say, I've said it
before and I'll say it again,
I'm not big on the stacking.
It's an aggressively stacked bagel.
Which makes it harder to
get everything on one bite.
Harry: We'll see how it holds up.
How big do they think my maw is?
I mean, I've got a pretty
big mouth, so I'll be fine.
Joe: Yeah. Not me, though.
Harry: Good luck.
Joe: All right.
OK.
Mm.
Joe: Cream cheese is definitely hitting.
Mm-hmm.
Joe: The salmon's fantastic.
Could do a little less tomato.
Not a fan of the tomato
or just too much of it?
Joe: Not a fan of it. Like,
one slice would've been fine.
Sure.
Now, first time we've done sesame bagel.
I'm liking it.
The bagel itself, excellent.
So, like, crispy-crunchy on the outside
and a good amount of
sponginess on the inside.
Joe: Oh, my God. And red onion?
This is, like, the
onioniest one we've had.
Harry: This is a very oniony bagel.
Joe: And I am not complaining, buddy.
I want to take just a
little bit of the salmon
and just try that on its own as well.
Mm.
So, I get more of a
smoked-salmon flavor from that,
which personally I love.
That's what I'm used to in the UK.
If you get salmon like this,
it's generally going to be smoked.
I just think it adds such a lovely flavor.
My thing's going sideways over here, bud.
Ooh, just bit into a caper. Caper bomb.
Harry: Caper bomb.
I'm going in. I'm going back in.
Joe: When I get everything
in a bite, fantastic.
Really impressed with the bagel.
Of all the bagels we've had,
maybe the crispiest on the outside.
Harry: Yeah, the crackle
as you bite into that
from the outside is so satisfying.
Joe: It's onion overload,
which might be overshadowing
the lox ever so slightly.
I got so much s--- in my teeth right now.
Harry: That's the
downside to sesame seeds.
Zoom in. Show me the monitor.
Harry: Oh, God. [laughs]
I got it.
Harry: One of my few
complaints about this is that
maybe they've done a little bit too much
because it's a slightly messy eat.
This was the original Xbox thickness
of bagel stacking that we've
had today. And I get it.
Some people, they're like,
"Yeah, I want a lot."
One thing I wanted you
to try they have here
is, how can I put this? Pastrami lox?
Those are two words that
don't really exist in the UK.
Joe: Figure out a way to make it together.
You want to check it out?
Harry: Absolutely.
Joe: So it is, look at that,
it's salmon that is
prepared like pastrami.
They got the pepper crust. Right?
Get a load of that.
So, as someone who's kind of, like,
as someone who's pretty new to pastrami,
what types of flavors
can I be expecting here?
This is a pastrami rub,
so it's going to be very pepper heavy,
but kind of a smokiness to it.
I think that's where you're
getting the smokiness from.
Because this was, this does
smell like it's been smoked.
Harry: Sure.
But that's not the exact salmon
that we've had on the bagel, right?
No, sir, this is different.
Ooh, this is so good.
Mm.
Joe: This is so good.
Does have a pastrami flavor to it, right?
Harry: It does.
Weird how they did that.
Harry: This is going to be
a slight insult to pastrami,
but the thing it reminds
me of is almost, like,
a hot-dog flavor.
Like, the frankfurter kind of seasoning.
I get that.
I will say this is nicer than a hot dog.
It's fantastic. I mean,
I want to have more,
but I think you guys
should try some of this.
Let's do Conner first and then, yeah,
let's get him, rip a bong hit on there.
Right? That tastes exactly like pastrami.
You're next.
It does kind of taste like a hot dog.
Joe: It tastes like pastrami.
Harry: Thank you. Hot dog.
Yeah, thank you.
I would be really tempted
to try that on my bagel
instead of just the standard lox.
Joe: Go. Go. Go. Put it on there.
Remake it.
Yeah?
Mm-hmm.
Don't get too full on bagelness.
We got another spot to go to.
And I don't know about you,
but I'm [burps] hungry for bagels, baby.
I could eat an almost
infinite number of bagels.
So let's go.
Joe: Let's go.
Our fourth and final stop was
to a New York bagel staple
since 1976.
Ess-a-Bagel.
This might be the most
localest favoritest spot.
And the most historic. It's
been here since the '70s.
Started by an Austrian family.
They have a bunch of locations now.
This isn't the first one.
Harry: It's a nice spot.
Joe: Yeah, it's a nice spot.
Lot of real estate here.
Joe: Yeah. Right by
Penn Station. Very nice.
Convenient to get to.
I want to see what the bagels are like.
Last one of the day.
Here we go.
Ooh, baby. Oh, mama.
Joe: Want to call to your attention
to the first and only appearance
of lettuce in our bagels.
Harry: Lettuce. In a bagel.
Is this common? Obviously, I guess not,
because it hasn't been in
any of the other places.
Joe: No, it is not.
Harry: How do you feel
about lettuce in a bagel?
Joe: I can't imagine the
lettuce swaying my opinion
too much on it, I don't think.
But I'll reserve that official POV
until after I bite into this.
Harry: Yeah. I think, like,
maybe this has one of the higher
filling-to-bread ratios
that we've had so far.
Joe: Oh, yeah. Good point.
Harry: This thing is
almost entirely filling.
Not a ton of bagel.
Joe: Not complaining.
Here we go. Bite. Go.
Harry: All right, man.
Mm.
I was wrong. I can really
taste the lettuce on this.
You do get the lettuce, yeah.
If I may.
Harry: Ooh, the lettuce is coming out.
The lettuce has been removed.
I will say we've had
a lot of bagels today,
and I feel like both of us
are still devouring these.
So make of that what you will.
Points off for the lettuce,
but everything else,
really generous with the
lox, don't you agree?
Harry: Yeah, it's thickly cut.
Joe: Thickly cut, right?
I thought so, too.
That's thickly cut. The
salmon tastes fresh.
Not, like, in-your-face fishy, but, like,
you can taste it, which is good.
Joe: I really love the thick lox.
I'm really impressed with it.
Mm! Mm!
I'd put this cream cheese again at, like,
the kind of gentler end of the scale,
which I know you've kind
of suggested that you like.
You know, I want the, like, too much of a
sour cream cheese flavor.
Joe: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Harry: The cook on the bagel is great.
You see these little
kind of blistery bits?
You can tell it's been kettled.
Gets that real nice crust on the outside.
If I was to get this again,
don't put lettuce anywhere near my bagel.
It's enough of biting something
and everything going this way.
I think lettuce is, like,
the, what do you call that?
Emulsifier of that. It's just like,
lettuce is like, "All right,
boys, we're out of here."
It's like when you try and, like,
pull the tablecloth out from the table
and everything just comes off with it.
I feel like that's the effect
that the lettuce is having.
That's a much better analogy.
Overall, really good. Really good.
Overall, still a very good bagel.
Now is the part of the episode
where we do the thing that
we always do at the end.
It's true.
We're going to decide
who had the best bagel.
All right. For me, I was looking for
a combination of everything
in a bite. Right?
So I was not very happy with stacking
at some of these places.
Obviously these are bagel places,
so every bagel had to be nice and pillowy,
but also crispy on the outside.
I think almost every bagel
we had today was fresh.
Harry: Mm-hmm.
Joe: Right?
I don't recall disliking any of the lox
at any of the places
we've been to, do you?
No. I think we've had varying levels
of smokiness versus just
straight lox flavor.
But overall, I think I agree.
Yeah, we've had fresh bagels,
high-quality ingredients
pretty much across the board.
It's a difficult decision.
I would say, broadly,
I've had some of the best
bagels of my life today.
When have you had a better bagel
than the bagels you had today?
What city were you in?
Harry: I don't think I have.
Joe: OK.
I do think that on average,
these definitely outrank
UK bagels, unfortunately.
Joe: Yeah, I'd say so too.
Harry: Whether it's the tap water,
the famous New York tap
water or something else.
But I wish that we
could take these bagels,
make them in the UK,
because I would be eating these so often.
Joe: It's amazing, right?
Yeah. Really, really good.
I'll just go and say right now, then,
my favorite bagel today was,
and which bagel of the two,
I'm just going to pick ...
Tompkins Square.
Harry: Nice.
Joe: Yeah.
There was just something
about the bagel and the lox.
Everything worked so well together.
I mean, we're really talking
about, out of all four of them,
we're talking millimeters
better as far as, like,
however we're ranking them,
we're measuring them, but,
so but Tompkins was just, like,
now that we've eaten all day
and I've had a chance to think about it,
fantastic bagels there.
Chalamet knows his stuff, huh?
Joe: Yeah, that's right.
Chally boy.
Again, it's like,
there's a hair in this.
Joe: Yeah.
I think it's Utopia for me.
Joe: Wow. OK. All right.
Harry: Those were really,
really good bagels.
It was the fact that they had
just come out of the oven.
They're churning out fresh bagels
all throughout the day.
You can go in there pretty much anytime,
breakfast, lunch, dinner,
and get a hot, fresh bagel.
I think the ratio of fillings was good,
ingredients were good quality,
everything in that bagel
just worked for me,
and I think it was excellent.
Considering that we've eaten
quite a lot of bagel today,
I'm still feeling pretty good.
Joe: I am stuffed to the
gills. I'm never eating again.
[Joe laughs]